all right i know there's been a lot of
alex jones stuff on today's program but
it really is an incredible situation now
as if things aren't already looking bad
enough for infowars conspiracy theorist
alex jones after getting caught lying
yesterday in cord and all of these other
things we are now learning that as a
result of what has come out in the
defamation trial the january 6 committee
is planning to subpoena alex jones this
is an exclusive from rolling stone
january 6 committee prepares to subpoena
alex jones texts and emails jones
lawyers in a sandy hook defamation case
fumbled three years worth of texts and
emails the committee would like to know
more about any contacts with donald
trump's team regarding the january 6th
capital attack this is uh oh and i'm not
logged in and we're not even gonna deal
with that right now i have another
article about this january sixth panel
set to subpoena alex jones after
revelations in defamation trial the
january 6 select committee is reportedly
planning to subpoena far-right
conspiracy theorist alex jones after his
texts and emails were revealed wednesday
in a defamation lawsuit filed by sandy
hook shooting victim families in a
cross-examination sandy hook victim's
attorney mark bankston told jones his
lawyer erroneously sent bankston three
years worth worth of the conspiracy
theorists emails and text messages
copied from his phone the january six
select committee
is now reportedly preparing to request
those records from the attorneys
representing the sandy hook victims to
investigate the deadly capital
insurrection this is just unbelievable
going from bad to worse for alex jones
and jones has managed to keep himself
more or less isolated from the january
6th committee probe
uh that appears to be ending at this
point in time and it would not shock me
i mean listen at this point i'm glad all
of this is happening this it genuinely
genuinely seems like this is what alex
jones deserves if we want to talk about
about
merit
but
alex jones must be considering do i fire
my attorneys do i have grounds for
appeal later based on improper
incompetent representation by council
because this is just going wrong for him
in absolutely every sense of the word
and there are
it is not completely implausible
that this could be the end of infowars
now if that's the case
i'm not going to
take pleasure in it from a personal
perspective but i do think it's
important to be able to have a
conversation about
is this entity a net positive or a net
negative for the world and for society
and there's a real question about that
to put it lightly to understate it when
it comes to infowars so we're going to
be watching all of this let's hope that
the january 6 committee does get those
texts why well because we should know to
what degree alex jones was coordinating
with people in trump's circle so that's
the latest there and we'll do one more
alex jones thing before we move on